-That's why you do it.
That's Jeff Daniels.
See, this is
why you do it, right?
-It's why you do it.
It's why I'm back
in "Mockingbird."
I'll tell you, it's --
-It's the audience.
-It's the live audience,
that electricity you feel.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Right?
It gives you the energy.
Jeff, I consider you one of the
best actors in the business.
-Big statement.
-Well, I do.
I do, and --
-Well, thank you.
-I was trying out some
characters in the monologue,
and I just -- and I think --
I don't know.
I just want, maybe, your notes.
-For the baseball-bat thing?
-Yeah, yeah.
You saw it?
-I thought it was good.
-You did, right?
Did you believe
that I was a bookie?
-It had -- Well, it had --
If Jerry Lewis was a bookie.
[ Laughter ]
It had that kind of --
"Baseball bat"!
-"Baseball bat!"
But that keeps you guessing.
You go, "Hey, is this guy
gonna break my legs?"
-Exactly.
-You don't know, it keeps you --
-Which is what you want.
-Thank you, yeah.
I didn't get the part, but --
You know...
[ Laughter ]
Again, I could do
lots of different things.
If there's, like, an extra
in "To Kill a Mockingbird"
or something like that,
I'm down the street.
-Sure, sure.
[ Laughter ]
-You know,
you need someone to come on,
just give me a line.
-Give you a line?
-Sure.
Give me a line, I'll do it.
-Uh, uh, uh...
-And you're Atticus, right?
-Yeah, I'm Atticus.
Uh, uh...
-What do you want, Mr. Ewell?
-Okay. Ready.
Oh, I'm Mr. Ewell?
-You're Bob Ewell.
You're the bad guy.
-Mr. Ewell was my dad.
Call me Bob.
[ Laughter ]
How about that?
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
Improvising.
"What do you want, Mr. Ewell?",
and then Mr. Ewell turns,
and he goes,
"Mr. Ewell's my father.
Call me Bob."
[ Laughter ]
Right?
-Sure.
-Yeah, don't --
You think about it.
I'm down the street.
I'll give you my cell again.
-The part is cast.
The part is cast, unfortunately.
I saw that you and your wife --
You were recently --
You were in the press because
she threw out the first pitch.
It was interesting.
Because you were supposed to
throw out the first pitch
at a Pittsburgh Pirates game?
-We were shooting
"American Rust"
in Pittsburgh, yes.
-Did she know at all?
-The Pira--
We called the Pirates,
and, you know, being one of
the few celebrities
in Pittsburgh at the moment,
they said yes.
And they said, "We'll put you
in the suite with the owner,"
and I said,
"Well, it's my wife's birthday.
Could you just get her a cake
in the suite?
Maybe the mascot could show up."
'Cause we've been married
42 years.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm -- I'm --
Well, but...
I have run out of ideas.
-You're out of ideas.
-There is nothing.
She's going,
"How about a little --"
I said, "No, no, I'm done.
I can't." And then I said,
"A cake, maybe the mascot.
I might get away
with the birthday that way."
We're walking
into the Pirates thing,
and the Pirates P.R. people
are there, and they said,
"Would you like your wife
to throw out the first pitch?"
And I said,
"Yes, and don't tell her."
[ Laughter ]
So, we get there,
and we get to the dugout, and we
go, "Okay, Jeff, it's time."
And I go,
"All right, Kathleen, come on."
She goes, "What?" I'm like,
"Come on, come on, come on."
And she is from
the upper peninsula of Michigan,
so she can dig in and go,
"I ain't moving.
I ain't moving.
No, this is not happening."
So I'm dragging her,
and she starts to go --
Now we get out to the --
Now we're out to the mound,
and I have the ball,
and she goes,
"What am I doing out here?"
I said, "Here, you're gonna
throw the first pitch."
-In front of everybody.
-And then I -- yeah.
And we've got, you know, fans --
-Stadium.
Maybe 15,000, I don't know.
And so I'm backing up.
And she's going, "I can't
believe you're doing this."
[ Laughter ]
"What are you doing?"
-42 years, that's right.
-And I'm to the home plate,
and now I'm going, "Oh, my God.
I gotta catch it,"
because if she throws it and
actor boy doesn't catch it...
-Oh, then the whole bit's --
-Then it's viral.
So now I'm just --
So, I'm like those guys
at the tarmac
when the plane's coming in,
with the orange, I'm going,
"Anywhere in here!"
[ Laughter ]
-Anywhere, yeah.
Of course.
-"I love you, honey!
I'm sorry I did this!"
-"I'm begging you."
-And she does one of these,
and then she threw it.
-We have the video.
Let's take a look at the video.
Here we go.
-Yeah! Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That is love.
[ Laughs ]
That's love right there.
I want to talk about
"American Rust."
It's on Showtime.
It's fantastic.
I've seen two episodes,
I believe.
-I love stories about
small-town people but told
not in a way that Hollywood does
where they come in
and polish it up and, you know,
Hollywood people come --
You know, it's like, I want you
to feel like you're in the town.
So it's real.
Authentic.
And the writing on it
is so strong.
These are good people,
decent people who are just
trying to survive, and they're
making some bad choices.
There's a murder involved,
and --
But it's more about
the people around it.
And it's just -- I got some
really good people in it.
And I'm real proud of it.
The first three episodes
that have been up are just,
like, the setup.
What happens later is just --
you can't even --
you don't even --
-Oh, really?
-You think you know
what's gonna happen --
-I think I do.
-Pwooo!
-Oh, really?
-Yeah, it's one of those.
So I'm real excited about it.
-Oh, wow.
I'm even more excited now,
because I'm invested.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Jeff Daniels
in "American Rust."
Take a look at this.
-Chief Harris,
how long ago did you
release Novick from his duties?
-About six months.
Hey, I took him to N.A.
I helped him work his program.
He was clean
for a good long while.
Why am I even defending myself?
-Because you allowed an officer
using illegal substances
to remain on your force
during a drug epidemic.
-You want to indict me,
you know where I work.
Tucker, are we done here?
-I believe so, yes.
-Then, Sheriff,
if you don't mind,
I'd like to return
my former officer's
personal effects to his widow.
You okay with
how I'm spending my morning?
-I am, Chief.
-Thank you.
You all have a pleasant day.
-That's what I'm talking about.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Jeff Daniels, everybody!
"American rust" airs Sundays
at 10:00 p.m. on Showtime.
And "To Kill a Mockingbird"
opens October 5th.
Chloe Fineman
joins us after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
Come on back.